[Music]
it's a Monday edition of PFT ot PFT p.m.
PFT more than what we do during the two
hours that we're live on PFT live Chris
Sims Mike Florio and Chris the draft is
only ten days away Jo burrow continues
to be the consensus number one overall
pick the bengals continue to hold that
first pick in the draft and there's a
little bit of news as it relates to what
the bengals are possibly thinking about
doing albert Brewer of si.com points out
that the Bengals have used all of their
allotted time to talk to borough in
advance of the draft now because there
are no in-person meetings no private
workouts the pro days had the plug
pulled early in the pandemic you can
talk to any number of prospects that
you'll want you can talk to all of them
if you want to and you can talk to any
of them three times per week up to one
hour per conversation so math sometimes
a challenge for me this is simple three
hours per week of video or phone time
with Jo burrow that's what the Bengals
have been doing every week of this
pandemic that's a lot of time talking to
a guy that it sure looks like they're
gonna be drafting in ten days Chris well
yeah but you know I think you know
realistically Mike a lot of the times
when these type of visits happen during
a regular offseason you spend a full day
with that player like he comes to your
facility at 9:00 a.m. in the morning and
you have dinner with him that night and
drive them back to his hotel you know at
10:00 p.m. that night so it's 12 and
13-hour days and maybe even a follow up
the next morning who knows what it may
be so you know this is a huge investment
the Cincinnati Bengals wanted to get to
know Joe borough as the person but I'm
sure deep diving into his football
knowledge as well and I'm sure they want
to know you know every little tidbit
about him one because yes he possibly
will be the face of the franchise two if
they had a quarterback you know that
they think is almost up there as far as
their top
on their board that they think is
comparable you know they might want to
get a feel for what Joe burrow is - in
case they wanted to trade the spot trade
it away and maybe take another
quarterback okay well we know this guy
this is what we're gonna be missing out
on so there's a lot of different angles
that play here but man Mike the one
thing I hear repeatedly is that Joe
burrow is an absolute stud in meetings
behind closed doors whatever it may be
and you know just being around him a
little bit of the combine Mike you could
tell he's that way he's got a you know
I'm the sheriff I'm Peyton Manning I'm
telling you he really does he's got a
great aura and and what do I want to say
presence about him in a room and I think
that's showing to a lot of people who
are talking to him and you make a great
point that we need to emphasize because
for example when Washington does the
full workup on the quarterbacks it'll be
available number two to a Tonga Milo
adjust and Herbert it doesn't mean
they're necessarily interested in
drafting them if you're gonna trade that
pick you need to know everything you can
know about the player because the team
isn't moving up because it wants to have
the second pick in the draft or the
first pick in the draft is the case
maybe the team is moving up to get the
player so you know when you're trading a
guy who's on your team you already know
everything you need to know about him
when you're trading a draft pick that's
going to be used for a certain player
you need to find out everything you can
now look I think it's far more likely
the Bengals are spending this time with
borough because they intend to take him
and this is an opportunity to get to
know him better at a time when there's
not going to be an offseason program but
yeah if there is going to be an offer
from a team like the Dolphins to move up
to number one the more you know about
borough the more you can engage in a
real and meaningful negotiation and you
know a lot of stuff about the guy and
right we're but you know when they say
well do we think that's too much we
think this we think that you could say
now you're wrong about that we think
this we think that so so it's valuable
and and it's kind of unlike the Bengals
to be that far ahead of the curve if
they are thinking about doing this for
the purposes of setting up a trade Chris
I think they're doing it because they
want to take the guy and they're taking
full advantage of the time they have
available to get to know him
for him to get to know the coaching
staff because once he's picked they're
not gonna see him until training camp
whenever training camp maybe ya know and
you know Mike I think you hit all the
right points
you know you said it you know one I
think it's always good to do some due
diligence on the top quarterbacks you
never know who might come your way four
or five years from now in free agency
and now you have an inventory of
knowledge built up on the player to the
point you made is spot-on you know again
if Cincinnati's looking at their and
going man this guy might be paid Manning
oh you want to come get him well we
think he might be paid Manning so you're
gonna have to blow us away and that's
gonna you know raise the trade offer you
know so or whoever if the Redskins are
in that conversation with you know judge
Justin Herbert or two or whoever it may
be but that's the reason you do your
deal gelatin suited to what you're
saying you want to know what you're
trading away and what kind of player you
view him as and what he possibly could
be
since you're training him for another
team and the marquee could leave on the
NFL and that leads right into a question
from William eight six eight three six
zero four five got to get those numbers
right got to get the names right what do
you want to know this what would it take
for the Dolphins to pry Joe burrow away
from the Bengals now keep in mind Peter
King reported today that neither coach
Brian Flores no gene or GM Chris Grier
of the Dolphins want to make that huge
moved want to give up what they have to
give up to move from number five to
number one to get Joe burrow but what do
you think it would take ultimately to
get the Bengals attention Chris well I
think it could be you know two
first-round picks
you know whether that's in this year's
draft or you know a pick from this
year's draft and next year's draft as
far as the first rounders go and
probably something as far as a second
rounder is concerned to be thrown into
it I mean it's gonna be a very very
expensive price tag to pay up the trade
up from number five to number one these
are elite commodities in the NFL world
as you and I both know I mean the number
one pick you should be getting the best
player or certainly one of the
two or three best players in the draft
according to a little bit to what your
positional need is on your football team
so I think it'll be big-time price tag
and I would tell the Miami Dolphins or
anybody does listen to don't do it
negative Ghost Rider build your football
team you have too many holes on your
roster you know to me the one player is
not worth it as awesome as I think Joe
burrow is Mike you know I don't think
the difference between Joe burrow and
Justin Herbert is worth trading you know
three picks that might be in the first
two rounds of the NFL Draft I don't
think he's that much better so that's
where I would tell you the Miami
Dolphins hey just build your football
team here not one guy is gonna make the
difference and are you saying that it
would be the fifth overall pick this
year plus another first rounder and a
second rounder is that what you're
saying yeah yeah I think so yes they'd
probably have to Swift the you know
switch to five in the first round the
five and the one this year and maybe
throw in the one that's in the twenty
seventh number 26 this year along with
it they might have to give two of those
this year or at least the number five
from this year and next year's number
one pick along with the second round
pick from either this year next year I
think it would take something like that
yes to move up to the number one spot
now
when Washington moved up from six to two
the same movement the same number of
spots in 2012 they gave up pick six to
first rounders on top of the sixth
overall pick and a second rounder so I
think it's gonna cost even more I think
that is it more it's I think I think
it's three ones and a two and now it's
it's your first rounder plus two more
and a two so it's not three first
rounders you know wow it's it is I mean
that's what we were switching one you're
trading one of the first rounders but
here's the thing
anytime you draft a player with the
first-round pick you are trading a
first-round pick for that player so so
to get Joe borough it's going to take
three first-round picks and a
second-round pick you have to give
Cincinnati the five
and to first-round picks on top of it
along with a - I think that's what's
gonna take now remember the Dolphins
have nobody right number 18 and number
26 so but here's the thing and here's
why I think there's pushback from Flores
and Greer I think Joe burrow is coveted
by owner Steven Ross I know he is
I know Ross loves him and at some point
it doesn't matter what Flores in Greer
think Chris what matters is what the
owner says and if the owner says what is
the bottom line demand from the bengals
and let's offer it what are they gonna
do quit right the boss is the final say
you can say that someone's contract
gives them the final say Bologna the bus
has the final say and if Ross wants
borough if Ross didn't want to roll the
dice on tua and his hip problems or
Justin Herbert where there's this
concern that he's never left Oregon and
how is he gonna do 3,000 miles away in
South Florida almost as far away as you
could possibly get from Oregon right
let's just go ahead and make the
investment and get the guy who is the
clear no-brainer
our next Dan Marino type of a
quarterback I could see Ross saying what
the hell nothing else we've done is
worked let's go ahead and give up the
draft picks and let's go get this guy
well I want to say but a lot of the
reasons the none of the none of the
other stuff has worked that they've done
to this point is because he sticks his
nose into the conversation too much so
that should be case in point to just go
no you're great at real estate and you
made a lot of money in other ways it
wasn't coaching or evaluating football
players mr. Onur I'm sorry I know you
got a lot of zeros after a big number on
your bank account doesn't mean you know
everything in the world why did you hire
Brian Flores and Chris gear then I mean
crap [ __ ] just pay yourself and be the
head coach of the GM then you know so I
don't know what else to say there that
that to me would be the wrong approach
and yeah okay even if you like Joe
borough that much man Hima you must
think he's so much better than any of
the other quarterbacks out there in this
trap or even next year's draft and also
I would say man you're gonna lose a huge
support system to make sure that player
works within
organization by trading away all those
assets so yeah it's dicey I'm Mike
you're right I mean there's no way I'm
trading away three first-round picks to
move up you know first off I would tell
you this
Justin Herbert alright I think has more
of AI has a higher ceiling than Joe
burrow as a player so I would think it
would be insane from that standpoint and
you're probably right Mike I was
probably a little low on my overall
price tag you know you're right it did
probably take two first round picks
maybe a second two second round picks to
go with it or maybe it does take all
three first round picks but that's
insane in itself to me no no no almost
no player is worth all those commodities
and Chris one of the things I really
respect about Jerry Jones he cut out the
middleman he's not gonna put some puppet
in there that he's gonna tell what to do
yeah I'll go ahead and I'll be the
general manager let me tell you it
probably did cross his mind at some
point about also being the head coach if
I'm gonna make these decisions and I'm
gonna tell these guys what to do then
I'll go ahead and I'll be that guy so I
respect that's so much more than an
owner who medals and tries to act like
he doesn't metal like a Jimmy Haslam
does in Cleveland oh I didn't say pick
Johnny Manziel Yeah right you didn't say
pick Johnny Manziel of course you did
and if you didn't you made a damn
clearer than anybody who wanted to
remain employed by you was gonna pick
Johnny Manziel just be the guy go ahead
and be the GM if you're gonna be that
involved in telling your staff what to
do about their draft picks well yeah I
mean an - what you're saying - Mike I
mean with Jerry Jones I mean he acts
like a GM he puts in the work like a GM
he's sitting there front row with the
NFL Combine he's always there on the
field to value any players so he yes
he's the owner but really what you see
it's a guy that's around practice every
day always at the games that at the
senior ball you know at the combine
always getting a real first-hand look at
these guys so if you want to be the
owner and do that that's fine but you
need to go all in on the football aspect
of the job and that's where the Jerry
Jones is special yeah he
the football team and does all the
business dealings but man he loves
football he loves evaluating players and
he is always there in the middle of the
action to make sure he's got a good feel
for it so he acts more like a GM really
than he does an owner in a lot of ways
he also likes doing some deals and that
leads to our next question from Sean
Carroll any truth to the rumors about
Dallas checking in again on Jets safety
Jamal Adams and I hadn't actually seen
those rumors but I know the rumors were
rampant during football season and look
I think once a team entertains the
possibility of trading a guy he remains
in that bubble of possible trade until
he is traded and if the Cowboys really
want him and if Jamal Adams really wants
to play for the Cowboys and if the Jets
have misgivings about Adams great from a
talent standpoint maybe a little bit of
a pain in the butt at times if Adam GaSe
the coach of the team is thinking my
life will be easier I don't have to
worry about it because you know for a
lot of these coaches 5% of the guys
caused 95% of your headaches maybe and
I'm not saying Jamal Adams is a problem
but look I'm not saying that this trade
won't happen the fact that they
entertained the possibility last year
makes it a possibility now have you
heard anything and do you think there's
anything to this possibility that the
Cowboys swoop in and make a move for
Jamal Adams well I always got the
feeling that up here in the New York
area there was a sense just from people
around the situation that they've got
some type of offer that they felt you
know blew the doors off that they
wouldn't they would give up a Jamal
Adams and the Cowboys you know as we've
talked about and I know this is the
position I said that in our draft last
week we'll be talking about the NFC's
that I don't think they can lead the
draft without a safety you know this has
been a position they've been trying to
you know change or bolster on their
roster for the last few years we knew
they were in there Earl Thomas trade
conversations you know a year or two ago
so I get it but I would tell the New
York Jets
all right so one mic I've heard nothing
substantial to make me believe that's
real ok - I would tell the New York Jets
man whoo Jamal
Adams is you know arguably the best
player on your football team you don't
have a lot of difference makers he's a
guy on Sunday that can make plays and
win football games for ya I would have a
hard time giving up that type of player
and I would think the price tag is
pretty steep right now to get that type
of player and I'm not so sure I can
picture Dallas and Jerry Jones at this
point in his life wanting to give those
assets away just for one guy when he
knows he's got a team that's very close
and I would think he would want you know
more of the picks and things to kind of
fill some roster spots here and there
yeah I I agree I don't think the safety
puts them over the edge and I don't go
oh they're a Super Bowl contender now if
they get the safety I don't look at it
like that that roster has been quietly
ravaged this offseason we focused so
much on DAC and Zeke and Amar'e they've
lost some talent and III think it's
gonna make I think it's gonna make for
some real challenges for this team to be
competitive they were eight and eight
last year I don't see them being
dramatically better this year unless
Mike McCarthy
has something up his sleeve or is a hell
of a lot better coach inherently than
Jason Garrett all right a couple more
quick ones here Scott
Pollock ten will the Seahawks address
their offensive line in the draft and I
mean I I let's let's narrow it down to
will they address the draft will they
draft the offensive line early in the
draft Chris I would expect that it would
be something in the first two rounds you
know I would you know I think when I
look at their roster more than anything
and it doesn't seem like Jadeveon
Clowney is gonna be back in the fold
there in Seattle at least not at this
point you know to me that first pick at
the end of the first round
I would imagine could be between a pass
rusher or or that offensive lineman now
the offensive line you know has made
improvements the last few years it's not
the same offensive linemen we saw it
offensive line we saw two and three
years ago where we met man Russell
Wilson's got no chance know them trading
for Dwane Brown
a few draft picks of you know
you know come come about and help them
out as far as pockets enter and things
like that so I do think they address the
o-line I'm just not sure it's gonna be
about a little bit of what's available
there I think at pic what is it Mike 27
and how they value the gotten the top
tackle left on the board at that point
and the top edge rusher on the board at
that point I think a lot will come down
to you know where the value is greater
therefore that end of the first round
type thing and one thing John snare to
the GM of the Seahawks loves to do is
trade down and trade out of round one
Peter King has the history here in in
2019 they traded from 21 to 30 2018 18
to 27 2017 26 to 31 34 to 34 then 34 to
31 to 34 then 34 to 35 trade it down in
2016
traded the first-round pick in 2015 for
Jimmy Graham traded down in 2014 traded
first-round pick for Percy Harvin in
2013 and traded down in 2012 so every
year since 2012 they've either traded
down one or more times in round one or
traded their first-round pick for a
player so whatever they do Chris count
on them to trade down before they do it
wouldn't be shocked I mean I get it
you know they like New England have
great confidence and their ability to
find down the line guys where they go
yeah you know everybody thinks this guy
is a top 30 pick well we found a guy we
feel like that everybody's valuing it
you know a top 90 pick but we think he's
very close really in value to being that
top thirty pick you know the Seahawks
John Schneider Pete Carroll that's why
they've been relevant so long they have
consistently drafted well and found a
way to build the football team yes maybe
they held on to some of their stars from
that Super Bowl team a year or two long
a year or two too long but overall this
is why here we are you know nine years
later talking about Seattle still being
one of the best teams in the NFC and the
NFL is because of Schneider and Pete
Carroll's ability to evaluate talent and
then also evaluate how it fits into
their system
as a person but how the player will fit
into their scheme and that's where
they're awesome I mean that's why
they're one of the best in football
should they be concerned about their
ability to find down the line guys this
year given the limitations on the
information that ordinarily would be
available I don't think so
I think these guys have a keen eye for
what they see on film and both of them
Mike as we both know have unbelievable
social skills so there are they're
capable of taking guys that we might
call most teams might go oh my gosh I
can't deal with Marshawn Lynch oh my
gosh I can't deal with Jadeveon Clowney
that's a scary
that's a scary proposition ODK Metcalf
he has a nose ring and he's a he doesn't
run the full about tree at Ole Miss you
know they just say no screw it we know
the guy we're good with people we know
him well enough to know he'll fit in
here they do their due diligence as far
as I think their area Scouts have a good
a good job of scouting the people not
necessarily the player so they
understand that and then they have great
confidence in their ability to translate
their people skills to making guys work
on their football team all right one
more question and I only address this
now because I saw a column yesterday
from Dave Burkett of the Detroit Free
Press that delved into the issue of what
will happen if there's no football
season in 2020 and look none of us want
that but we also don't want the NFL to
be caught unprepared and I think the NFL
needs to be ready for anything and
everything that can happen and one thing
they need to be ready for is no season
at all and one thing that comes from
that what does it mean for the draft in
2021 so that's the question what would
you like the NFL to do with the 2021
draft if the entire NFL season is god
forbid cancelled some kind of a lottery
keep the same order and let the Bengals
have the first pick two years in a row
etc that question comes from will Louis
here's what Dave Roquette wrote about
yesterday the NHL in 2005 Chris when
they were coming off of a year with no
hockey due to a lockout they had a
lottery that was based upon three years
performance and if you didn't make it to
the playoffs or didn't have the number
one overall pick in any of those three
years or in the fourth year because
there was a draft the prior year before
that
you got three balls in the lottery if
you either didn't make it to the
playoffs or didn't have the number one
overall pick you got two balls in the
lottery and every one when else got one
ball in the lottery and that was their
way of harmonizing the folks who said
everyone should have an equal chance it
should be a straight lottery regardless
of anyone's past performance and those
who wanted only teams that didn't make
it to the playoffs in the three years
that they have played prior to that
draft to be in contention for the first
overall pick the bottom line is the NFL
is gonna have to come up with something
whether it's a blended lottery whether
it's all teams with equal shot you can't
just say we're gonna redo the order from
2020 there was no season it's all driven
by how the team performs in the prior
season if there's no season you need to
have something different and there will
be factions and there will be people
with self-interest and there will be
people advocating for an approach that
meshes with what they think benefits
them and the NFL is gonna have to figure
this out Chris I hope it doesn't come to
it but you know what I've been saying
the NFL should have a draft lottery and
maybe the first one they have is a
product of necessity and they realize
hey this is a pretty good thing maybe we
should do this every year well I mean
yeah I you know this is a way above my
pay grade this is very complicated
subject one for one you know - you know
I also think about you know from this
standpoint Mike if you're a team who
made the playoffs just this past season
right but now you're kind of in like
okay that's the end of the shelf life of
that football team we need to rebuild
and change our team to where maybe a
team was willing to accept that that
might be one of the 10 worst teams in
football next year or 12 worst teams of
football next year but now they made the
playoffs the two years prior this or
three years prior to this our total
rebuild mode and now they don't get one
of those three balls that's in the top
ten pick category so I that's where I
worry about it it's really tough I mean
man this is yeah this is gonna have to
be a well thought out
says where you get the competition
community all 32 NFL head coaches and
try to figure out something with the
brightest football minds we have that
makes sense and it's fair for everyone
that's the big thing in but man yeah go
ahead but I'm scared it's come to it I
don't want it to come to it but here's
the thing
the virus controls the timeline and we
can be stubborn right but look at what's
stubborn goddess from January in
February one of the reasons why so many
people are dead and still dying now we
have to be realistic we have to be
pragmatic and until there's a vaccine
for this virus we're not gonna have
70,000 people in stadiums no we're gonna
want to go until there's a vaccine or
until there's a treatment that is easy
is taking one pill and you've kicked
this thing's butt
so there's a lot of work that still
needs to be done behavior has to change
certain behaviors already have changed
sports have gone into mothballs they'll
find a way I think to play the season
they'll move heaven and earth to play
the season like the but but still
there's a a set of circumstances that
says no matter what the NFL does Chris
they still can't play the season so they
have to be ready for everything and we
need to be prepared for whatever may
come you know it's gonna be
disappointing if there's no football
season but we have to be ready for
whatever may happen we can't get so
invested in one outcome that we can't
handle it if it doesn't work out the way
we think it's gonna work out man that'll
be torture I don't know what the hell
I'll do with myself I mean gosh what are
we going to talk about okay and you know
- you know Mike I'm already coming
around to the fact that we're not gonna
have fans in the stadium for at least
the first six eight weeks of the stadium
of the year I mean there's no freaking
way people are gonna feel comfortable by
September at least the way it looks
right now to go oh yeah I'll get in the
city and with 70,000 people a wall touch
the same railings and you know armrests
on the the chairs in the stadium and do
all that no I think that's just gonna be
too scary you know I'm coming to where
you know as we're seeing here with more
for evidence I don't think the players
give a damn about koban 19 and I
understand that and I'm not trying to
say it's not right with some of the
things we've done like I'm not trying to
say that but I just know when I was 24
or 25 years old football player I
thought I was indestructible it's part
of the reason I lost my spleen I was
always like God doesn't matter who hits
me you can't hurt me and I think that's
the mind frame of a lot of these players
to where I do wonder Mike if you know at
some point will the players sign some
sort of waiver and go hey we're gonna
play football this year the NFLPA we
agree on it we're gonna do it we'll
still make all the sacrifices that are
necessary to help Society but the NFL
will have to spend top dollar to you
know make sure there's doctors on-site
daily players and coaches constantly
getting tested and keeping the
precautions of hey like you're not gonna
see mom and dad or grandma this year
after the football games it's just the
way it's got to be but I would hope that
we could find some way to make football
happen I honestly think Mike at this
point and we keep going this way it'll
be for the betterment of America if the
players and coaches and people in the
NFL are willing to make the sacrifice
and we might lose money from though fans
in the stands but the ratings are gonna
be through the roof I mean I don't give
a damn if there's no fans there for
Saints bucks you know with Drew Brees
and Tom Brady in fact I'm gonna like it
even more I'll be able to hear Drew
Brees and Tom Brady when they cuss out
players on the field for running the
wrong ride or not protecting it might be
more fun you know so that's what I'm
really hoping for it might be selfish I
would want it done the right way but I
really think the players are gonna be up
for this yeah it all comes down to what
the circumstances are going to be what
restrictions will be put on their lives
when they're not at the facility because
once that virus gets in the locker room
it can run roughshod through it and look
I know that it's a ridiculous example
and one of the reasons I put it out
there was to try to encourage the NFL to
begin the process of having a plan but
the idea of tech you know they've talked
about doing it for baseball you take
everybody to one place and look it's a
huge sacrifice if you've got a family
you're going
leave your family for four months I
don't know the guys are gonna willingly
do that but if guys want to play and if
that's the only way that it can work and
I still don't think it can work there
are too many moving parts too many
logistics too many issues like taking
guys away from their families they'd
have to build this mega facility out in
the middle of nowhere to facilitate all
the games and have have residences for
the players and the coaches and everyone
who had to be there but they got to be
thinking about every idea even the crazy
dude what what is every step you know if
if we can't have fans what can we do if
we can't play in our regular stadiums
what can we do if we can't play games in
California what do we do you know if
there's stay-at-home orders what do we
do how do we make this work they need to
be working on it now they don't want to
wake up in June or July when they
realize whatever ideas they have they
don't have enough time to come to a
conclusion as to whether or not it's
practical they need to be doing it now
they needed to be doing it a month ago
and I'm concerned if they haven't been
doing it enough all right we've spoken
enough for today two hours on air
another half-hour here it's PFT ot Chris
you've got an unbuttoned coming up
tomorrow what do you have planned for it
yep tomorrow we're gonna get into D B's
everything secondary Mike I'm gonna rank
the corners rank the Safety's been
watching film with them all week so
excited to do that Kristin's up button
got Tuesday Thursday this week gonna be
doing a interview with Arik Armstead
later today - that would be released at
some point later this week - so excited
for that alright buddy well hey great
work as always and try to pick a spot
and stay there you're moving around okay
too much although I like I like the
window shot earlier I actually did okay
like that especially if there's a chance
that we're gonna see Phil's head go by
that window at some point Mike it's your
show so you asked you shall receive
tomorrow the window shot coming for you
all right all right good deal
Chris great as always everybody will see
you tomorrow have a great day check us
out a Pro Football Talk AMA see you a
Tuesday morning
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports